these are the heroes and demigods of
modern capitalist mythology we tell and
retell their biographies while
generating their inspiring works if
there is such a thing as winning the
game of life most people would say this
is it our media is fairly obsessed with
entrepreneurs whether it's shark tank
inventors celebrity restaurant tours
merch Hawking vloggers or makeup
tutorial moguls
we're bombarded with messages that
suggest that entrepreneurship is the
only path to real wealth and fulfillment
everyone feels the pressure to quit the
day job reach for the stars and be your
own boss but as any successful
entrepreneur will tell you it's not for
everyone the autonomy and independence
can be fulfilling but you'll probably be
working longer hours for less money at
least at first and having a great
product or visionary artistic talent is
just one small element whether you want
to be a freelance graphic designer
an Instagram influencer or the inventor
of a squirrel shocking bird feeder oh
it's a thing look it up most of your
time will be taken up with new tasks and
duties that you may or may not find
enjoyable so before you quit your
nine-to-five let us show you some of the
many hats you'll have to wear it if you
want to be your own boss
[Applause]
[Music]
so you think your cupcakes are the bomb
and decided to start your own business
congratulations you're not just a baker
anymore now you're a CFO cash is the
lifeblood of any business and no matter
how much people like your product if
you're not balancing revenue and
expenses correctly your biz will pull
you out
the two main skills a CFO needs are
budgeting and accounting budgeting is
deciding how to spend your money to get
the most bang for your buck it means
being realistic about what you have to
work with and eliminating waste whenever
possible if you've never kept a personal
home budget you might want to start one
to get some practice accounting is
minding your business's financial
records which includes tracking your
income and costs estimating your
quarterly taxes and maybe even payroll
you'll probably have to learn an
accounting program like QuickBooks or
maybe hire a bookkeeper to lighten the
load but most entrepreneurs will tell
you that you'll always have to be
involved
no one will care about these numbers as
much as you do in addition to being CFO
you are also now the head of your
company's human resources department
that means you're in charge of hiring
firing training delegating tasks and
responsibilities as well as figuring out
payroll and benefits for your staff
what's that you don't have a staff yet
yes you do yourself leaving a salaried
position means finding your own health
insurance selecting your own retirement
plan and picking up the slack for
payroll taxes that you used to split
with your employer when it is time to
bring on employees finding talented and
dedicated people and keeping them happy
is essential many entrepreneurs credit
their success with being able to attract
and retain employees smarter than
themselves there are lots of awesome
books and podcasts on assembling and
managing teams and we'll make sure to
share our favorites in the doobly-doo as
a supervisor you're not just a manager
of people but also of time time is money
as they say and making sure that neither
you nor your employees are wasting it is
crucial our friend Chelsea over at the
financial diet wanted to give her two
cents on the biggest lessons she's
learned when it comes to managing time
so here's what I did wrong when I first
made the jump to being in
entrepreneur I tried to force a normal
schedule it made me feel like I was
working harder if I forced myself to
work into that nine-to-five even if that
wasn't when I was getting my best work
done I would save the easy little things
for last because often when I didn't
have a fixed timeline throughout my day
that meant just pushing off the tasks
that I didn't really want to do and felt
like I could do later and the third
thing I did wrong was forcing myself to
have bigger chunks of offline time
essentially taking weekends and
vacations as the time when I would
totally unplug and this is how I fixed
them instead of forcing myself to fit
into a nine-to-five I leaned into the
times that I did my best work and in
many cases for me being a night owl that
meant getting work done at night when my
brain was thinking it's best the fact
that you're able to set your own
schedule as an entrepreneur or
self-employed person is something you
should take advantage of not fight
secondly I started doing all those easy
little things first thing in the morning
because I found that when I got them
right out of the way I felt accomplished
and that sense of accomplishment
snowballed into being able to take care
of bigger and bigger tasks and plus all
that little easy stuff didn't keep
falling to the bottom or get kicked down
to the never slot on my to-do list and
lastly I started spacing out my offline
time giving myself dedicated chunks even
throughout my day where I was away from
my computer and specifically forcing
myself not to work when you don't have
dedicated work days and vacation days
you can constantly be pressuring and
guilting yourself into getting more and
more work done and ultimately that
leaves you more drained and unproductive
so by dedicating those offline times
throughout my day and throughout my week
I was often feeling refreshed and not
like I had to force every minute into a
work minute
the next hat you wear is the big one
marketing director attracting customers
to your brand is an enormous job you've
got to conduct market research create
and test advertising design promotional
materials manage social media accounts
and more and know a few random posts
the Instagram aren't gonna get it
marketing is a complicated multi-layered
discipline that involves statistics
psychology and art if you're lucky
enough to afford it you can hire a
specialist to help you though many small
business owners have to figure this out
on their own at first luckily there are
plenty of free resources like this
episode on market research we did a few
weeks ago for many new entrepreneurs the
hardest realization about marketing is
that the job is never done even if your
product is a stone cold hit you will
always have to keep reminding people
about it even coca-cola still advertises
once you're head of marketing has
attracted a bunch of potential customers
it's time for your salesperson to seal
the deal that's you again if marketing
is your public image sales is your
personal relationship with customers
being a good salesperson doesn't come by
intuition but by honing and practicing
skills like active listening or
networking effectively in a room full of
strangers
you'll also need to learn how to roll
with rejection without taking it
personally and how to create a
repeatable step-by-step process that
nurtures potential customers all the way
from initial interest to the sale and
beyond
and finally there's wait finally there's
so much we haven't talked about there's
logistics customer service legal not to
mention the hard to nail down soft
skills like keeping yourself motivated
and dealing with a regular income no I
know but while we don't want them to
have rose-colored glasses we don't want
to totally scare them off honestly so
much of this can and will come with time
and experience if you have the fortitude
and patience and if this doesn't sound
like it's for you that's okay for many
people having a solid day job they enjoy
can be more fulfilling and less
stressful than wearing all these hats at
once and that's our two cents
thanks to Chelsea for contributing to
this episode for more fresh takes on
personal finance you can subscribe to
the financial diet on YouTube if you've
started your own business what was the
best piece of advice you received be
sure to share it with us in the comments
you
[Music]